[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur es
welche gibt es ein neues update
unterhauses endlich fertig und ich zeige
euch mal eine kleine rundtour
[Musik]
okay es war nur spaß wir sind hier auf
dem schloss bückeburg und ich zeige euch
jetzt etwas schönes machen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt im eingangsbereich des
weihnachtszaubers auf dem schloss
bückeburg und ich muss sagen ist
wirklich das schönste weihnachtsmarkt
den ich je gesehen habe
man zahlt am eingang eintritt und von
diesem eintritt kommt zum beispiel auch
ein teil für die stiftung lesen zugute
wegen der ich eben auch hier bin ich bin
nämlich leser botschafterin und
unterstützt sie gerne die stiftung lesen
es gibt selbst in deutschland einfach
noch viel zu viele analphabeten und
menschen die nicht lesen und schreiben
können und dem kann man eben vorbeugen
und deswegen bin ich sehr gerne lese
botschafterin der stiftung lesen
wir sind jetzt hier auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt und ich zeige euch den
hierzu mal kurz es wirklich wunderschön
und nicht wie so ein normaler
weihnachtsmarkt wo es nur glühwein und
kinderpunsch gibt danke murad von
kinderpunsch sondern hier gibt's auch so
sie sind schon inklusive werden später
die fürstliche hofreitschule sehen und
haben auch ganz viele shows hier man
kann wirklich hier den ganzen tag oder
auch die ganze woche verbringen und ich
nehme euch jetzt mal mit in den
weihnachtszauber
[Musik]
die historische jahrmarkt
was ganz besonderes
[Musik]
weiter geht's
jetzt nämlich hier geradezu schaute mir
sind schon heute ein bisschen frühjahr
um 16.30 ließ der bühne geschichte vor
das wird richtig toll er ist nämlich
briefe von italienischen kindern an den
weihnachtsmann vor dann die sich zwei
tolle weihnachtsgeschichten vor und dann
mit gebacken und da besuchen mich ganz
viele zuschauer
[Musik]
lecker und liebe weihnachtsmarkt
da oben übrigens das sind unsere
schlafzimmer wären heute nacht schon
hier auf dem schloss geschlafen und ich
habe mir noch gefragt was ist das da
unten
da kann man also von da oben direkt hier
auf diesen waldpark und schauen echt
schön
ich hab den weihnachtszauber muss man
echt sehr aufmerksam sein und auf diese
vielen kleinen details achten so wie
hier die versteckten figuren oder hier
vorne da steht einfach ein schaukelpferd
unter dem baum und wie viel es ist
einfach nur ein schaukelpferd für mich
macht diesen weihnachtsmarkt einfach
wirklich unvergleichbar und wirklich
einzigartig und daher sollte man ihn
wirklich gesucht
[Musik]
was ich aber meinen braves pferd
da hat mir jetzt gerade gezeigt wie man
hier im hintergrund arbeitet und zwar so
dass handgearbeiteter mundgeblasene
gläser und ein ganz toller tipp an euch
wenn ihr so etwas kaufen möchte dann
könnt ihr immer darauf achten wenn ihr
mit beiden fingern darüber vater ist
hier oben immer so ein rand und der
kommt immer dann zustande wenn es
wirklich reine handarbeit ist und wenn
der rand oben glattweg ist also wenn da
nicht dieser rand ist dann ist es
maschinen arbeit
[Musik]
hier stehen wir jetzt an der kapelle
hier seht ihr das schloss zur kapelle
das ist schon über 600 jahre alt und hat
aber bis heute noch die rechnung vom
schloss verweisen ivan das finanzamt
kommt es hat sehr viele funktionen
jetzt geht noch rein
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir gerade in der fürstlichen
kapelle und das ist alles wirklich
richtig wunderschön also das schloss ist
ja über 700 jahre alt und die kapelle
über 600 jahre alt wird ja alles immer
in etappen gebaut und sieht einfach
wunderschön aus also man sieht wirklich
jeder zentimeter hier im raum ist bemalt
früher glaubte man auch dass wenn der
weiße stelle an der decke oder an den
wänden bleibt das dann das böse ein
trinkt und so wurde jeder
quadratzentimeter bemalt mit hand
natürlich und es sieht also mich
beeindruckt das hier total
alles ist sehr gut erhalten und hier
finden auch heute noch gottesdienste der
familie statt und so wird einfach die
tradition bewahrt
hier auf dem bodensee tier zum beispiel
diese wunderschönen fließen und auf den
fliesen erkennt man hier auf dem boden
diese kleinen kreuzchen und die stehen
einfach symbolisch auch für die herzen
der toten
also ich weiß es nicht ob symbolisch vor
ort tatsächlich so war
es wurden die herzen dann entnommen von
den menschen weil man eben auch glaubt
dass im herz die seele steckt und dass
gute steckt und so konnte man eben
sicherstellen dass die toten der familie
noch nahe bleiben
die wurden dann hier begraben und hier
auch mit gold so ein bisschen überzogen
und so waren die toten einfach immer der
familie und auch gott
[Musik]
ich sitze jetzt hier in der fürstlichen
loge der kapelle
wir durften hier nach oben und ich hatte
wirklich einen wunderschönen blick hier
direkt auf die kapelle und hier sind
auch zwei figuren und zwar sind es keine
zwei engel sondern das sind tugenden und
zwar ist hier links direkt von der longe
die figur potenzial und zwar hat die
einen januskopf das heißt zwei augen
schaue nach unten aber zwei schauen auch
nach hinten
und es sollte den fürsten oder die
fürstliche familie immer daran erinnern
sich auf der erde so zu benehmen dass
man später wenn man tot ist bei gott
auch rechenschaft ablegen kann
also man muss sich immer daran erinnern
da führte steht über allen menschen und
er muss sich eben immer vorbildlich
benehmen und daher steht hier die figur
potenzieren
jetzt haben wir unsere tour fertig
himmels ein bisschen schneller sein denn
dafür ist es katrin und ist somit tag
und wir kennen es aber bereinigt glauben
doch sie ist die kurz darauf zeigte sich
nicht nur die füße feuerwehr ist die
politik
ich glaube die waren ganz unverstellt es
war voll komisch ist für mich ganz
schwer heute auf schloss bückeburg und
sally backt und dies vor und schließt
nur vor
wir sind bei der leser botschafter für
die stiftung lesen das auch so
berechtigt gerne ab so sehr wie es über
lesen fördert die entwicklung der kinder
und ich kann nur jedem empfehlen jeden
tag ca halbe stunde im vorlesen und
wieder um alles
mehr lesen hat hat macht und kann
es ist mir ganz wichtig also weiter
geht's auf der suche nach dem fürsten
richtige für mich dafür
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
jetzt hat er gerade bei der fürstlichen
hofreitschule auf der welt gibt es nur
noch fünf stück insgesamt die einen
tisch in wien das ist auch die größte
und die älteste und hier auf dem schloss
bückeburg also wirklich was richtig
richtig besonderes
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der ersten geschichte geht um den
herrn krause und herr krause ist schon
ein bisschen älter und hat auch kinder
und möchte aber dieses jahr weihnachten
eigentlich alleine verbringen
aber es kommt ganz anders heiner krause
war ein angenehmer enterte her klein ein
wenig unter selbst trotz seiner fast 80
jahren noch gut zu fuß
freundlich und immer gut zu einer klaus
aufgelegt ohne jedoch viel über sich
preiszugeben oder gar schwarz haft zu
sein
kurzum die bewohner deswegen den weg 37
machten auch in sehen kaum haben
[Musik]
ja für uns ist der weihnachtszauber
schon vorbei ich habe mir gedacht ich
zeige euch das schloss einmal noch bei
nacht ist es wirklich wunderschön
also sieht richtig romantisch aus mit
den vielen lichtern hier im
schlossgarten und es waren für uns
einfach zwei unvergessliche tage
die tage waren viel zu kurz um alles zu
besichtigen was ihr verpasst haben war
zum beispiel die pädagogisch der
pädagogische ziel kunst und zwar kann
man da am wochenende mit den kindern hin
sowie samira zum beispiel das kind
abgeben dann lernen die dort was ganz
tolles kunststücke zum beispiel und am
nachmittag führen sie das dann den
eltern vor also richtig schön wer
hierher kommt hat wirklich ein
familienerlebnis für alle
für mich war natürlich ganz besonders
dass ich damit die stiftung lesen
unterstützen konnte als lese
botschafterin das vorlesen der zwei
geschichten war wunderschön und alle
haben uns dazu gehört und es war einfach
ein ganz tolles erlebnis gerade waren
wir noch mit dem fürsten essen und auch
das war ein ganz tolles erlebnis ich
glaube das erlebt man nicht jeden tag
hier und ich habe mich so ein bisschen
gefühlt wie david bei den warriors in
england wobei ich nicht weiß wie man
sich da fühlen aber genau so stelle ich
mir das in etwa vor allem menschen eine
super sympathisch und es war einfach
eine ganz tolle erfahrung
nächstes jahr werden wir wieder
herkommen eins habe ich bereue ich hatte
die kinder leider nicht dabei und im
nächsten jahr werde ich bestimmt meine
zwei kinder auch mitnehmen und die
werden sich dann hier auch vom
weihnachtszauber ja so ein bisschen
verzaubern lassen also ich hoffe euch
hat das video gefallen und wir sehen uns
dann das nächste mal wieder biss dann
kann schon mal bitte die butter geben
natürlich james kannst die butter geben
sein kamerad sally kannst du mir bitte
das salz geben natürlich morath james
kannst du morath bitte das salz geben
er wurde durch
[Musik]
serbien
geht sind wir unseren kindern eigentlich
unseren kindern denken dann geht es seit
gut morath dankeschön sinn
danke jamie du die torten queen war
zusammen mit dominik ein tierisches
meisterwerk und jetzt kommt's ja
spannend teil du bist jetzt in der mitte
sondern hohem schaft erfahren nämlich
die bonbons eine bunte kerzen torte
führt doch links schwester inklusive
überraschung damit selbst richtiges weg
sagt er
sally bott sonntag 15 uhr